SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
We're here at KubeCon Barcelona,
and with me is Vila Aikas.
He is one of the most
humble engineers I know.
He wants me to introduce
himself as a software engineer,
but he is co-founder, one
of the original co-founders
of Kubernetes, as well as
a co-founder of Knative.
So let's start with Kubernetes.
Can you tell me about how
it's evolved over time?
And this is probably one of the
biggest KubeCons we've been to.
VILLE AIKAS: This is amazing.
It's amazing how
it keeps growing.
Every year, you
come in and you just
see how much it's growing,
how many new users are coming,
the solutions that people are
building on top of Kubernetes.
It's just beyond wildest
dreams of when we started it.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, it
is absolutely crazy.
There are so many people.
Now you've been involved
with a new project, Knative,
which has turned
into a hosted Google
solution called Cloud Run.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
VILLE AIKAS: Sure.
So Knative grew out
of the fact that we
were like, Kubernetes is
great, but it's really
hard for the developers to use.
There's a lot of pieces you
need to understand about it.
So I like to think of
it always as Kubernetes,
we did the cloud native
assembly language.
And with the Knative,
we are building
tooling on top of it that
allows people to then build
cooler things on top of that.
So it started out as an open
source product called Knative.
It provides server-less
computing primitives
and building blocks that
you can go ahead and use
to build your own
software much easier,
rather than having to deal with
the native primitive Kubernetes
resources.
And it is also an API spec.
So what you see is
on the Cloud Run,
we were able to go ahead and
provide a hosted product, where
you can use the API without
not even having a Kubernetes
cluster to manage yourself.
But we understand that
there's a lot of environments
where we're going to provide
these computing capabilities.
So Cloud Run is one where you
don't even see any cluster.
There is no cluster.
It's the cluster-less compute.
And then all the way
to your own host,
if you have a
bare-metal Kubernetes,
you can run it on there.
And we are seeing
more and more products
also being built
on top of Knative.
So Cloud Run is one of them.
There's others--
Pivotal, Red Pad.
I think Rancher just launched
something yesterday or today.
So it's grown as well.
SAAD ALI: Nice.
So what is the current status
of Knative and of Cloud Run?
VILLE AIKAS: Sure.
So we are-- on the
Knative side, we
are on a six-week
release schedule.
So every six weeks, we
will cut a new release.
We have a couple
of different stacks
there, so we want to make sure
that you can come in and either
take all of them, and I think
the term being described
is Voltron effect.
When you use all
of them together,
everything works much,
much, much better.
But you can also go ahead
and come in and host only
the pieces that you care about.
So some of those are serving
and eventing, also has build.
So if you, for example,
have your own build system,
you're happy with that, great.
We don't care.
You can just use serving
or eventing itself.
So what we have working
on the serving side
is really closely--
we are working very hard to
getting it to 1.0 release.
We just dropped
two weeks ago 0.6,
and eventing is a
little bit behind.
So we are going to go ahead and
release serving first, and then
eventing.
But hopefully sometime
in the fall time period,
we'll be in the 1.0 release.
SAAD ALI: So as a
customer, why would I
choose to run on Cloud Run?
VILLE AIKAS: Ease of management.
So you don't have to
care about-- you just
give us the code, and we run it
for you, scale it down to zero.
So you truly get the server-less
benefits of scale to zero,
pay only for what you use,
request base, and so forth.
So on the Cloud
Run on the hosted,
you just give us the
code, we run it for you,
and you don't have to worry
about managing anything.
You can also do this on GKE.
So we have Cloud Run on GKE,
where if you have a cluster,
or you have other
computing needs that you
want to go and do on
GKE, then the great thing
is that you can just go and
install a Cloud Run GKE add-on.
And then you can go and
still use the same API.
So you can pick and choose.
And then, of course, you
can install the open source
Knative yourself onto any
cluster, any Kubernetes
cluster.
SAAD ALI: Very cool.
So basically, you can use the
Knative API through Cloud Run.
But if you want to drop
down into a lower level,
you can basically go and
access a GKE cluster directly.
VILLE AIKAS: That's correct.
Yup.
SAAD ALI: Very cool.
So where are we
going in the future?
What are you excited about next?
VILLE AIKAS: I'm excited about
a couple of different things.
One of them is getting it
to GA, 1.0 release, where
we feel that it's ready to go.
The second thing is
seeing the community grow.
So again, kind of like what
we see with the Kubernetes
in the early days, it's great
to go and come up with thoughts
and ideas and share them.
But what's really interesting
is when people start then
building products on top
of that, like we've seen,
as well as the users.
So we are seeing a
lot of developers
coming in and
joining the community
and providing a lot of great
ideas, great contributions.
It's awesome.
SAAD ALI: That is great.
So last question.
What are you looking forward
to at KubeCon this year?
VILLE AIKAS: Just seeing
a lot of old friends,
seeing all the cool things
that are being built, and--
yeah, and just the community.
It's just awesome.
SAAD ALI: All right.
Thank you so much for your time.
Take care.
VILLE AIKAS: Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]